my buddy from uh he's well look he's
known as the man who uh created uh
uh the the phrase coin the phrase
football heaven
uh and his first ballot pro football
hall of famer but in my household he's
known as uncle marshall
back here on the rich eyes and show a
long time friend of the program
2-8 how are you sir i'm good man i'm
good how's it going how are you doing
wow
i'm better for talking to you i'm better
for talking to you
um i i tried to um
just to bring you up to speed i uh i had
clay chase claypool
on the other day i tried to nickname him
the chase chiro
um but he's he's not taking that one
marshall can you honestly just tell rich
to give it up with this
yeah that yeah
you gotta let that one go rich that
one's not good no
why didn't you let that one go so you're
saying that clay pool like that's just
that's that's a you don't need to you
don't need to
nickname anybody that has that as a name
claypool that's just like
well you know he's six foot four he's
from he's six foot four he's from canada
apparently the real nickname he's going
by is
mapletron instead of megatron
mapletron is what he's going with right
now marshall
wow yeah so that's why i tried to you
know kick it up a notch that sounds like
the mattie isa situation
[Laughter]
marshall apparently he's already
trademarked it and he brought it with
him from notre dame
how about that but that's saying a lot
it sure is uh all right let's get into
the news of the day with you
what's going through le'veon bell's mind
today do you think
he listen he literally gets to go be on
the winner that's what he's saying
you normally don't get this you normally
don't get this so he got his money
and now he got his freedom and he can go
play for a winner
think about it
i mean annie has his health which is
probably the most
that's like took last year off
was it last year oh no the year the year
he took off before he left this dealer
and then last year he didn't play a lot
and then what no preseason
i mean he's uh he's a spring chicken as
far as running backs go
yeah i mean it's just you know i don't
want to go down the jets wormhole here
but now that he is free and his
options according to adam schefter are
the dolphins bills and chiefs which one
would you choose
marshall let's see dolphins
bills and cheats if i'm him
[Music]
i'm never ever playing with a suspect
quarterback again
right so i'm going with the chiefs
there's no question about the
quarterback play i want to play i want
it
here's the thing people don't understand
how hard it is to be a productive
running back
when your quarterback is not respected
in the lead
but when your quarterback is respected
and
and they have to decide do we keep an
extra safety back or not
then you have running holes you have
running room
but when he's not oh my god they have a
safety in the box and the deep safety is
like 12 yards back
because they don't respect your
quarterback
so obviously if you're looking at
quarterbacks just straight up it's
why wouldn't you choose the chiefs in my
homes especially on top you love the
enemy too
i know that and you know oh yeah you
know and eric is
uh a former running back himself and
he's dialing up all sorts of evil and
personally i've got my eye on him to
hook up with trevor lawrence in green in
new york city in 2021 but that's for
another day
um so uh i understand that
let me flip it on its head which i know
you enjoy uh
having that thrown in your direction are
you saying that josh allen is not to be
respected
or he's not yet respected what are you
saying about that
i'm i'm saying that
that in the grand scheme of things if
a defensive coordinator had to decide
who is going to beat them the running
game or josh allen
they're stopping the running game and
they're going to make josh allen make
the tough throws
that's what i'm saying and what about
the concept that edward zelaire is
sitting there and they drafted him first
overall
why why do you think the chiefs would be
interested in bell and what he would
have to
suss out there before he jumped on board
marshall falcon
well it's not it's not it's not what
it's not what clyde can and cannot do
it's it's it's it's like hold on wait
think about this you have tariccio
you have watkins i mean
how many how many weapons you can't have
enough weapons
if you can get him on the cheap if you
can get left bail on the cheap
why not do you think this means
something that uh that
that uh the chiefs have seen in edward
zelaire and that he's not yet ready to
be the bell cow
for this team no what do you think it is
not at all okay
not not at all not at all what this
means is
you have an opportunity to to add a
le'veon bell
to the arsenal of what you have in an
offense
that's it it's not it's not it has
nothing to do the question is
chemistry wise is there leadership
within the locker room enough
that that that level is going to toe the
line
can he told the party live that's what
it's all about
what do you think when you look at it
when you look at it
if lev bell wants to play next year
if he goes to the chiefs with that
high-powered offense
and all the things that people have to
worry about he's just another
pawn on the chessboard that andy and
and and eric get to move around and play
with
he doesn't have to worry about being the
bail kyle
he gets to share the backfield with a
young guy
and then next year after being
productive
it's like okay now i'm a free agent i
showed you guys i can still play
because he went from he he would be
going from one extreme with the jets
where you have no help to be extreme
to another extreme with the chief where
you have more help than you could ever
ask for
from no house there's a more speed at
receiver tight end
they have everything you could ever want
so then why why what are the choices
then
i guess one one's got no state taxes and
he he's probably got a spot in south
beach and the other one is the bills
they went knocking on his door maybe
they were the first ones
out of the gate i mean when uh then we
should expect to see him in kansas city
by the end of the day apparently he's
already followed patrick
mahomes on twitter that was noticed last
night
marshall if here's what i might say
after after leaving pittsburgh and
playing with rockets burger
he got a chance to see what it's like
to to be in the backfield and look at
your quarterback and have your
quarterback look at you
and not know more it's like
you okay you okay oh okay we're in
trouble
it's a tough one rich it's a tough one
oh my god
you never had that did you you never had
that right
did you ever have that hey man hey man
been around a long time rich been around
a long time
did i just raise a lot of raised a lot
of guys man raised a lot of guys no
okay i've been in that backfield with a
lot of guys it's been the first time
it has not been their first time but for
the most part what you do is
you know every every some people can
handle that position
when you're there and you like you you
work with guys that's young or
guys that that you know that they need
they need confirmation and what they see
is what they see
and some people can't you know i was
able to do that i have to accredit to do
that
pro football hall of famer marsha falk
here on the rich eisen show
let's get into it as on this subject
marshall you and i were texting over the
weekend
uh just a couple hours after dak had
that awful
season ending injury requiring surgery
and a four to six month rehab
uh i give you the floor on youth how you
think this
injury will play out uh throughout the
league with players
watching from afar yeah it's
you know i i can't imagine that
players will be playing on on that
tinder now
it's it's like what do you do um
and this is this is this is it rich this
is like it
and we we i i believe we all believe
that dak is coming back that's the idea
he'll be back
um but if he if
if this was it like let's just say this
was it and he didn't play another down
my question is what would jerry hire him
to do
like what would he then be like
what role would he have with the cowboys
or would it just be
sol like what would it be
like what cowboy fans who have one of
those hundred thousand dollar boxes up
there
that was upset because he was holding
out waiting to get money and didn't want
to play
what what deals what they put him in so
he can continue to make money like what
would they do
how would they look out for his family
that's all i want to know
because they see it it's a sport in the
game to them
but for us you know that got it he got a
family to take care of
so what what what what role do you think
it would play in terms of players
accepting
um maybe a little bit less than for a
long-term contract part of the reason
why well i just think
i think i think the league i think the
league they got to get rid of that
like that's that's that's i mean that
like that that
i mean i i just don't like what what you
can do with that
the franchise tender is that that is
what you're saying yeah
yeah and playing on it like playing on
it
what you're exposing
to not play what it means and then when
you go and play what
what you're risking
that's a lot have you connected with
zeke since the injury
to dak have you talked about it you've
done oh no
but but i'm gonna tell you one thing
yeah and i don't know if you guys saw it
i don't know if you guys watched the
game
the minute that that happened all of a
sudden that offensive line that wasn't
blocking as good dialed it up a notch
the defense that was giving up a lot
doubt it up a notch isn't that isn't
that weird
to what you owe that and let me let me
defend let me defend
tony dungy when he said a blessing in
disguise
my take of it was
that people are going to step up that
should have
should have stepped up sometimes
people don't see it's like you need to
they were relying on that to just bring
them back and do stuff
you know the birth of people sometimes
come out of
the absence of people well i know
you've never known what trip we would
have never known what kurt warner could
be
had new trend green got hurt and i know
you believe that not just because of
that because
you said on this show i think previewing
what you said on game day morning later
in the week or could be vice versa
uh when calvin johnson suddenly retired
on the lines you said
matthew stafford's gonna be better that
the offense will be better
and maybe in the similar way that we're
seeing carolina richard sherman said on
his podcast with uh chris collinsworth
that it that that that mccaffrey being
out
makes carolina less predictable
so it does you know it literally does
rich
it does it when you take that focus away
i'm telling you who else
drew brees in the saints not having
michael thomas out there
the relationships i mean people don't
understand how many balls this dude
caught last year that is unbelievable
it's unbelievable but it it it's making
it it makes the team better when you
take away
your like your best player and now you
have to go out and find ways to win
man you become a stronger team marshall
faulk here on the rich eisen show and
that has been part of the conversation
as well that brady
having a five touchdown performance with
a hobbled evans and no godwin
and o.j howard being carted off that it
did it'll come down
the road to be better off for the team
you're seeing how without devante adams
how
rogers is performing but at some point
though you do have to put it together to
make that super bowl run do you think
the cowboys
can do that with andy dalton without dak
now that you're seeing how
maybe the absence makes the heart grow
bigger
and your game have to be more focused i
guess
on that subject i i think i think
that why receive a core the receiving
core
for the cowboys
they they they have to expand their
catch radius
cedric wilson man oh my god
like i understand people talk about the
other guy
but how he has stepped up
and stepped into what he is doing for
the cowboys
um it's just i just love what he's
bringing to the table
but i think collectively as a group
their catch radius has to get wider um
their run after the catch has to get
better because andy dalton is a
facilitator
um he can he can he can he can do
certain things
he's not he's not a he's got to bring
you from behind win the ball game type
guy
but but he can he can help you win games
we've seen that
it was it was his problem was when you
get that 100 million dollars and we
talked about this rich when you get that
big contract
and now the components aren't around you
that once was that got you that money
can you win with less he's not that guy
but he can win with the guys that they
have because they have a really good
nucleus nucleus
of receivers and and and back
um that offensive line that used to be
the best in the league is
it's hobbles it's hard i mean they're
they're
it but i'ma tell you when dak went down
it was a different offensive line i got
about two minutes left here marshall uh
i know you're
you're kind of my sean payton whisperer
with him being your if i'm not mistaken
position coach right back in the day at
san diego state you've known him a very
long time
the saints are also your childhood team
um
and breeze breeze you you've known for a
very long time
what did you make of what's going on
with michael thomas and the suggestion
that he could be if we tear it bring it
all together
another version of le'veon bell or
antonio brown and what's going on there
how would you interpret the saints the
state of the saints right now um
it's tough man because you know they
they're good at keeping things in-house
and sean sean handles it you know he's
really good at that
he's um and i'm not saying other teams
don't
just my my my personal dealings with him
and just the conversation
you know he's a problem solver he
doesn't
he doesn't exacerbate problems you know
him and he's going to sit down
and it's like how do we move this
forward and get through this
and and move past this and that's that's
what that's what they do
if you if you look at any and everything
that the issues they've ever had that's
what they've always done
always so you're thinking this is going
to turn out okay
is that what you're saying that's what i
believe
okay i believe it's going to turn out
okay and do you think that
the struggles on offense is because of
thomas's absence or
where do you where do you land on the
drew brees arm strength
i guess conversation that's been
dominating for about a month
right now i mean
i'm assuming when i got older i got
slower so
i mean i lost some speed so it's
you will not if all the time is
undefeated
so he can say what he wants i mean his
arm is not the arm it once was the
question is can they win with his arm
the way it is
it's not about you know what i'm saying
we we said the same thing about peyton
manning his last year
right and that's all he did was when he
he won a super bowl with that arm
okay did you ever step first let's be
real like yeah quarterbacks are not
exempt
did you ever stiff arm somebody like
derek henry marshall
no oh my god no no
never once never once not
ever you never knock anybody out of the
football club
not like that rich i mean that was that
was like
i mean he he catapulted him and of all
guys of
all guys how do you get a talker
how do you get a talker like a guy who
just barks
all games well he if you remember last
year earl thomas
last year said bring him on uh in the
playoffs and he found earl and he gave
him an extra shove in the back when he
didn't even need to
remember that one man yeah that was
seriously that's like you don't do grown
men like that that's like i was like
that's somebody's father you don't do it
like that
that was embarrassing all right marshall
it's great catching up with you you take
care of yourself love you man
let's do this again man have a good one
right back at you that's marshall fall
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here